good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning shows happy Monday Wow it's
like last week was such a long week and
now here we are starting again how
exciting that's like life you know it's
like the whole your whole life is
waiting for the week to end and then it
ends and then all of a sudden it's
Monday again like the entire week you
did last week didn't even matter
yeah but I mean just so happy to be here
with all of you
honored humbled a blast so happy that
award season is over
same I had such like a crazy you know
content filled weekend like I really
became yeah like I really became like a
certified youtuber this weekend oh
because you were filming things or you
know because that was consuming content
I put the YouTube on my TV you know
YouTube I'm like actually grab yeah
that's the best thing that you could do
I'm representing the grandmas across the
world we love watching YouTube on the TV
but there's something I really like
about even if it's small like being so
close to my phone physically I'm the
opposite really
over there are people so I fell into the
vlog squad which like people haven't
Elling me about for a year it's like
david dobrik david rubric and it really
understands him and dry bread cuz like i
saw him like his time he's out of his
mouth and I was like what's like with
all the hype without but like oh my god
I've never been so wrong like I'm so
involved now like vlog squad we like
totally ship him and Natalie like so
essentially like he's just like this
like funny cool guy who like started
vlogging and it's so successful and all
he does in his videos just give away
money like he like Costa College
campuses he's like if you can hit this
best wall shot I'll give you $10,000 to
pay off your student debt and it's so
funny because anytime he like wants to
give away money and he's like cuz his
videos brought to you by SeatGeek sea
geek is like his ten bird you know I
love it I love to see it I nine give
away money but now I'm just like so
interested in his finances because he
said constantly giving away money like
to his friends he's buying all of his
friends cars but now that I'm like
involved in the sand hood like his
videos are all vlogs that are four
minutes to 20 seconds long money yeah
right SEOs birthday and he's the
chairman fan they can't monetize them
because he's always using music and like
doing like crazy like you know stunts so
he doesn't monetize them so he doesn't
make any money from his videos he's a
podcast which you know we support a
fellow podcasters now I'm just invested
in his pie
like to his merchants podcast making
that much and he can just be giving away
cars to people like what are we doing
wrong probably and I think people like
it's like Geoffrey Star said he had like
one room of Gucci and he's like this is
all YouTube ads like it's a fraction of
what people make if you're making real
money than the money that you make from
YouTube ads is tempting right but so
those are those are his other ventures
he I think he tours a little bit on that
Nickelodeon show most musical family
which I find to be so interesting
because before watching his vlogs I
thought he was like you know like a
really family friendly he's like not
like they're always like doing nuts
things and like cursing and talking
about dick well he's on Nickelodeon what
would you just see USA but get you a guy
who could do both like if he could be
family-friendly on Nickelodeon and
otherwise elsewhere then that's cool
with me you know whether it's cool to me
- I just think didn't think it'd be cool
to network's I think they could be cool
down trying Network sorry oh I mean if
Dan Schneider is cool with the network
the neutral really goes so true and I
just really feel like I like need to sit
down at my phone and watch 400 more
vlogs like he's kind of hot like you
know no I think that people are
attracted to him I think that's an idea
I think his assistant is totally in love
with him and I think he's in love with
his assistant Natalie he bought her two
cars and I just have a feeling like like
this whole story is gonna end with like
them they're like the Ross and Rachel
that's what I think and I'm just really
hoping that like Natalie and some of the
other girls in the vlog squatter
toasters that they like hear my cry and
like well let me get in the video or
something like I'll film I don't care
like I'll stand in the background I'll
I'll clean the toilets cool maybe I'll
come on the show maybe ya know would be
super fabulous speaking of the show
today such anything baked is the first
official episode of the redheads is out
people you know the scholars are the
academics academia world it's just
incredibly shocked waking waking like
they've never seen a launch like this in
their life you guys the first episode is
here we had so much fun recording it and
I think it's like I've been getting a
lot of really positive feedback I think
it's really good um we talked about the
book a lot and if you've read the book I
hope so you know but like I feel like
obviously most people are reading the
book and are waiting to finish the book
so they can listen to the episode but if
you have absolutely no interest in
reading the book I think you could still
listen to that's a good call because
like we're just friends hanging out
talking about major themes in the book
that like we pretty much explain enough
that you're not totally lost right so if
you don't want to read I think you could
sell us into the podcast but you
definitely should read because it's just
great for you
what also is nice about it is that since
you're doing it every month like you
don't have to listen to it today like if
you want to finish the book and a weed
yeah like it's there for you and you
don't feel pressure yeah did you assign
the next book the next book was assigned
at the end of the episode and it is red
white and royal blue its Becky's choice
okay um so you have a month to read that
book going forward the episodes will
drop on the first Thursday of every
month Super Bowl
yeah we're catching up with the first
book everyone's still finishing up so
many people are reading and I'm so
excited so whenever you're ready to read
the second book I'm literally not gonna
read the second book until two days
before we record because it takes me two
days to read a book and then it's out of
my head speaking of books I read Jessica
Simpson's no I don't know oh my god it's
staring at me like at the bottom of my
bed I just yeah I get myself to read you
have to read it you have to read it it's
not interest it's the best memoir I've
ever read my life really not only is the
tea so hot and she's not holding back
the right it's so well written
she's articulates like her innermost
thoughts in such a profound way and like
she's just such a precious gem of a
woman and like she like she'll take us
through a train of thought she had in
1999 yeah it's probably embarrassing but
she doesn't care oh I love that and it's
just like it's so faith-based and she is
who she is
from when she was 17 years old till now
and like she is just really an open book
um I said I Kindle with me cuz like
there was something like obviously more
juicy parts than others like John Mayer
I know
shame on you
I know but John Mayer has really
reformed I feel like like this book is
definitely like bringing him back to a
dark place in his life when he says
himself he is a recovering womanizer so
you know I'm not here to hold people
accountable for their mistakes they
agree but hash tag I say I'm with
Jessica of course also and she didn't
say anything about like you know where
he is today like right we're gonna recap
the Oscars but we just talked about
really quickly
Joaquin Phoenix being the voice of
canceled culture did you hear his face
oh my I was so funny I thought he was
the voice of veganism yeah it was all
over the place like he was talking about
the environment and then veganism and
like I had no idea what the point of his
message was but he said I'm so grateful
that like so many people in this room
decided to you know give me a second
chance because I know like when I was
younger an [ __ ] I was all over the
place and I was really difficult to work
with and I was like a monster so I'm
really glad that
we as humanity are beyond holding people
accountable for things they did years
ago like he was just really speaking
like to my soul and he was beating to
Twitter and it was kind of beautiful
even though was all over the place I
mean I love a wacky night Joaquin
Phoenix speech I love a Joaquin moment
yeah and I mean now with award season
being over the Joaquin moments are over
he goes back into his cabinet but he
sets the bar high for the Duggars
we're gonna recap the Oscars all the
looks all the awards those are our first
two stories - don't worry
it was incredibly boring I did take a
you know short 45-minute break in the
middle of the Oscars to watch Shahs of
Sunset
which actually deserves an Oscar because
it's the first episode you think you
know they haven't been filming for a
while they push back filming because MJ
was on bed rest from her pregnancy so
they push back they actually haven't
seen each other in like five months
literally the last time a lot of them
saw each other was reunion and you think
you know it takes a while to get back
into the swing of things
no first episode they're dropping bombs
Adam had a naked strip Jenga at his
house bulb Reza was out of town and he's
sending inappropriate text messages to
Destiny's friend Ali like very like this
is stuff like certain seasons like work
up - yeah and they're doing it all in
the first episode also I love that this
show like everyone has really grown and
they're all having kids now like really
thinking about getting married and
settling down they're buying houses all
the inside of their houses look exactly
the same it's like that Persian modern
look it's actually really car set I kind
of it's actually like a really cool vibe
they all really decorated their houses
really nicely and I feel like they're
all quietly like very wealthy I think
that they all grew up somewhat wealthy
but the show has made them all super
wealthy I think that's like the vibe
that I'm getting yeah probably
Golnesa Loch NESA is back and better
than ever he loved her she [ __ ]
twisted like literally it was actually
crazy to see like she went out to lunch
with destiny and they're having like a
little bit of an argument really destiny
is like so cool and she's very mellow
two seconds GG's standing up screaming
she goes outside smokes a joint it comes
back just like I'm sorry she so he does
and there's like obviously a storyline
involving where her friends are gonna
have to have an intervention saying that
she smokes too much weed like she's
addicted to weed but she's pregnant now
so I so assume she's stopped smoking
weed but whatever such a great show
can't recommend enough so I did miss
like 45 minutes of the Oscars but I
caught up on Twitter and it doesn't
really seem like I miss much
yeah I actually I started watching the
Oscars I wasn't gonna watch because I
was like I'm enjoying my Sunday
afternoon I
caught up on dynasty i watch the new
show Katie Keene first episode super
cute bike I look it was really cute
that's all I'm gonna say like you know
pilots just a pilot it's hard to yeah I
thought that was I know that I will like
I love the time I love right or Ross
like the style it's New York City it's
good it's good stuff I'm gonna give a
talking curb and I was just having the
time of my life and I was like I don't
wanna watch the Oscars but then everyone
in our family top is talking about the
Oscars so I put on the Oscars and I
watched until probably right after until
like Chrissy met sang oh that was enough
for me to turn my television as well
like I'm going back to curb like I don't
want to watch I'm done with award shows
I caught up on curb as well um just what
a stellar show you know yeah it's just
so good the new episode came out last
night so I actually what I'm trying to
say is I didn't watch the Oscars mostly
and we're gonna be recapping it right
now so I'm gonna find out a lot of stuff
I watched most of it and I did write
down some notes in my phone because
there was some cringe-worthy moments I
just had to talk about you had to share
with the class yeah okay well without
further ado it is time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast that's true and I don't
want to rush you you know because
everyone's you know living such busy
lives these days but I do have to take a
really quick moment to acknowledge the
fact that today's episode is brought to
you by liquid IV everyone's talking
about liquid IVs hydration multiplier
you've even heard about how much we love
it but have you heard about their latest
product of the liquid IV Energy
multiplier their energy multiplier
tastes amazing just like their
lemon-lime flavor just mix it in water
and drip and drink it energy multiplier
gives you a sustained energy boost with
no crash here's one of the things we
love most about like would I be there on
a mission to change the world they've
donated two million servings to date to
places like Haiti Uganda Puerto Rico and
Nepal with each purchase you make liquid
IV donates a serving to someone in need
around the world their premium matcha
and green energy blend taste delicious
and provides a lasting energy boost
throughout the day they contain a
mixture of teas and her herbs high in
antioxidants that help improve mood and
focus liquid IVs cellular transport
technology delivers an optional ratio of
nutrients for more efficient uptake they
power your morning feels long days at
work and provide a boost for those tough
workouts and in case you're hungover
it's all you need get 25% off when you
go to liquid IV calm and use the code
toast at checkout that's 25% off
anything you
on liquid Ivy's website just go to
liquid IV comm enter the promo code
toast to save 25% off and get better
hydration in energy that's liquid IV
calm promo code toast
don't wait start fueling your adventures
today ina don't wait okay first story
I'm sorry
first highlight of the Oscars uh Janelle
Monae opening the show speaking her mind
during her outstanding oscars opener she
kicked off Hollywood's biggest night
with an electrifying medley of songs
starting with an audition of rendition
of won't you be my neighbor
then she highlighted a lot of the years
snub films like mid Samar and Rocket Man
I should've so I was recommend snubbed
well the movie was the song wasn't
because they won and they were nominated
but no but the like it was snubbed in an
apparent Edgerton wasn't nominated okay
and I think he should have been I don't
I'm sure there were some other snobs but
there was a lot of snobs and she was
highlighting the snobs and she did a
greater yeah she's super talented and I
loved her red carpet dress uh one of I
think that might be my top look of the
night but I thought the performance was
kind of strange like it was just a
little all over the place and I couldn't
tell it like she was the host was she
the opener like there was so much going
on and I'm like did I miss the memo
where Janelle Monae was hosting the
Oscars like it was just it was a little
messy no it's cause like no one wants to
say like someone would rather emcee the
Oscars from start to finish then say
that they hosted it right no one wants
that target on their back
I don't mind or the format of award
shows without hosts signed I think it's
it's interesting I don't really care I
think a good host can make a show but I
can also break a show so whatever the
Oscars were so boring and I don't think
that anything could have helped it I
realized how much I need a host first of
all I was so excited for the Golden
Globes when Ricky Gervais see was
hosting I was like what is he gonna say
what is he gonna do it may made it built
up excitement like as opposed to just
sitting around watching these people get
Awards and then the dumbest thing that
they do at the Oscars is they bring
someone out to introduce who's going to
present it it's a presenter of the
presenter it's insane it's so many
people's like beanie Feldstein
presenting Mindy Kaling presenting an
award like this is a joke no that was
weird for sure and that's what and
that's because we don't have a hose um I
know we're gonna jump into the show but
I want to mention a few quick things
about the red car
that I just have to make people aware of
because I don't know if any people were
aware of the fact that on ABC um you
know who was hosting yeah Lily Aldridge
like is that weird and ABC was the big
one because the show was on ABC she and
I think it was Tamron hall and Ryan
Seacrest for a minute Ryan like ran from
E on to ABC I think I changed channels
for one second I'm watching E Ryan's
there did I go to the go to commercial
break so I go to Channel seven Ryan's
there again it was crazy um she actually
did pretty good there were a few moments
where she was like visibly nervous like
talking to Brad Pitt Leonardo DiCaprio
and she was just like um well yeah like
she was having a hard time but I I have
to imagine this wasn't you don't just
like get your first time at the Oscars
so you know that's so crazy it was a
really really interesting choice yeah
and she looked beautiful with who were
the other correspondents Tamron Hall oh
and right I just I said there's gonna be
other people that know so it was just
kind of strange oh and you later he has
30 people working the reporter - oh
that's a great one he was good I mean
he's great at his job great in the
opening yeah um any other row that's
Ryan was doing interviews inside the
Dolby theatre which I thought was really
interesting at like the last 15 minutes
he ran from the carpet inside and
interviewed a few people who maybe they
missed on the carpet or maybe who
skipped the carpet yeah it was kind of
cool that Charlize Theron was there um
Ryan was being a freak
especially on he was really being so
short with people like he could not have
shoved Natalie Portman well he couldn't
have shoved Natalie Department off of
the podium fast enough yet because
Saoirse Ronan was coming it was just
like Natalie Portman I think she was
like she looked embarrassed that is
embarrassed it was ruined you see like
Natalie Portman Saoirse Ronan like same
thing yeah my notes just says Ryan being
so weird and short that that's the whole
thing
he was just cutting people off left and
right there was a 10-second interview I
can't believe you watch the red carpet
like oh I only watch the last hour
especially because we've been seeing the
whole award season is the same people
over and over again like coming through
red carpet like what are they gonna say
in an interview I was honestly on
Twitter and Instagram just looking at
outfits cuz that's the only thing that
changes I was on Instagram looking at
outfits Steve Martin and Chris Rock kept
the night's a list audience on their
toes they was terrible hit hit Jericho
but honestly I think the best comedy duo
of the night has to go to Kristen Wiig
in Maya Rudolph think so oh my god they
were so funny like
to like show different emotions because
there were so many directors in the room
that was so funny and saying that they
should host next year well that's always
how it happened like I think people are
probably saying that about Steve Martin
and Chris Rock which I would agree with
too
that's always what happens like people
they it's like an audition yeah I mean I
I just will take anyhow and they were
really funny at first I was a confused
but then I think I was confused too and
honestly both of them couldn't have been
wearing ugly dresses so like up there
they just looked a little silly yeah I
was like it's a costume totally
idina menzel and an army of Elsa's
performed into the unknown okay I had
many thoughts because honestly like I'm
sorry but it was very disappointing
because here's here's why I was so
confused because okay so idina menzel is
up there along with pretty much the
Idina Menzel's of every other country
yeah so I love to the global messaging
you know the world is you know big and
small at the same time but I'm like this
is the best singers in the world like
and literally none of them could hit the
notes that girl who hit the final note
the Danish girl shame on her like she
was awful and I just thought that means
I just thought the vocals were so like
not up to par with with Oscars because
then like Cynthia areevo coming out and
it's like oh that's how you sing okay
like I just I can't believe like the
Oscars is the pinnacle of talent like
the pinnacle of everything of art and
film and music and this is this
performance is supposed to be
representative of the pinnacle of music
literally these girls like they just
weren't good singers oh my god idina
menzel she had some good moments but
amazing she couldnít that was so good in
their final into the unknown note
that girl was the best part she's only
one I've hit her notes well honestly if
I can hit those notes
anyone can Cynthia areevo like wow did
you see her performance no oh my god I
don't even know this song but I was like
I was speechless like it was
breathtaking her voice and by the way
she didn't move a muscle like she was
hitting these notes high/low didn't even
move like it was nothing for her she was
like it was spectacular it was and then
I'm like that next to idina menzel
and her danish friends who couldn't sing
i was like oh
Jaggi like you have to watch Cynthia are
you though it and you know I've heard
about Cynthia Revo I know she hasn't
seen her perform I knew she was in
Harriet I didn't know she's saying until
your husband told me names like you have
to hear her saying I'm my gaya whatever
but he was totally right because oh my
god she is incredible yes and that song
should have won literally because of her
performance which song won uh raka man
oh okay even though like I love Elton
John and I loved Rocket Man like I
wouldn't have chosen that song - me
neither because when he performed it I
might go great Elton John so for me or
what it was what he's gonna sing Rocket
Man you know I'm still standing and he's
like singing that song from the movie
and I just thought it was like a really
really subpar Elton John song and I
didn't think necessarily that he
deserved to win I
I would agree with that and then Diane
Warren you know who's out here getting
nominated 15 times for an Oscar and has
never won it's like let's just give it
to her you know it just has been 32
years I saw a headline today like this
memory continues it's crazy um she goes
to every Oscar sanam is nominated every
year and as number one she's like the
Leonardo DiCaprio it is really crazy
I loved the army of El says I do think
that they should have led with show
yourself and maybe they would have won
the award I'm a silly Eilish saying
during the in memoriam she's saying
yesterday by the Beatles how was it
spectacular
she is just such a talent and you know
what was so like she like what an honor
for her to have been given that like she
wasn't even on camera cuz they were
showing the pictures of like all the
celebrities had passed away it was
really just like a moment for her voice
to shine and it was shining bright like
a diamond like it was breathtaking love
it I know that Luke Perry and Cameron
Boyce were left out of In Memoriam
oh you're right not cool no the only
people who I had recognized was Kirk
Douglas who passed away recently and
Kobe Bryant
yeah own Doris
Brad Pitt won his first ever acting
Oscar oh my god and he was so [ __ ]
cute he was sitting the first row and I
know it's Oscars but it was next level
star-studded yeah Brad leo
Bradley Cooper Penelope Cruz who like
hasn't left her house in a month
Charlize Margot Robbie yep it was just
spectacular and I just have to say
Penelope Cruz like just a moment for her
dress she's up there with my top three
best strats like she just looked like
she is the definition like if you were
open the dictionary and you looked up
the word everything of the sort
Pepe Cruz would be right there yeah I'm
really happy for Bryan I'm glad we got
another Brad Pitt speech moment like
just to round out this award season it
was nice she has made it all worthwhile
even though I couldn't make it till the
end of this Oscar is it was it was a
great speech it was a great I just would
like to highlight a couple more moments
I wrote down there this is so many
moment Jeff Bezos
yeah Jeff Bezos was in the audience
which is the weirdest thing ever and
Steve Martin and Chris Rock acknowledged
his presence and I just felt like I felt
weird
I think everyone felt weird Jeff Bezos
looked weird like he was freaking me out
it was like dad get out of here but at
least he had a good attitude about it
and he was smiling and laughing and he
could laugh at himself like I was
worried he seems really sensitive I know
it's like volatile because he was such
like an open B was so vulnerable for the
world just seems so emotional and then
the last thing I wanted to discuss is
the absolute travesty that was Chrissy
bats okay because I was gonna call you
out cuz you're like giving in Tina
Menzel such a hard time I'm not time yet
okay okay I first of all I didn't
understand why she was there but then I
found out that the song that she was
singing that was written by Diane Warren
was um in her movie breakthrough which
wasn't nominated for anything except the
film was so the person singing always
has to be like connected in some way so
I I get I guess why they chose her I
read an article Diane Warren did not
want her to sing it but then she heard
her sing and said okay she's good she's
a community theater voice it's like oh
it's like a fun party trick it's like oh
wow you're amazing actress oh and you
kind of can sing doesn't mean you sing
at the Oscars and there's I mean you
sing for Lou Combs and then to be so
disgraceful as to literally finished
singing and be like I love you mom
that's literally what you did I was like
what the [ __ ] this is
this is the Oscars Chrissy this is not
community theater shilling he was like
yeah I love you mom like right before
they turn the lights out it was a
travesty and honestly shame on her it
was disgraceful I'm sorry okay just
because you can sing doesn't mean you
should yeah at the Oscars unless you're
me who sings the song in the movie not
Chrissie Matz I don't know but but you
know who's Chrissie Mets is number one
fan in terms of her music yeah Brian
Kelly he's always listening to her like
when we're hanging out and drinking he's
like always try to make me listen well
do you remember that time that she yes
of course at like some country awards
cuz I guess he couldn't make it so she
sang his song it was just like again a
disgrace it was nothing of the sort
no I mean that one she actually sang it
very poorly and no and we love that song
let me care for that's not she saying
even though I'm leaving and just didn't
do it justice and she couldn't find her
key the whole time at least last night
she wasn't off pitch I don't wanna I
just think it was I love you mom like it
was just so disrespectful I am sorry
okay well parasite made Oscars history
last night I'm so happy for the
directors they're so cute so [ __ ]
cute getting up there I drink till next
morning so cute I just love him say when
when they won their first award and one
of them was talking the other one was
just off to the side staring at his
award like he just was smiling he
couldn't believe it I have to see this
movie I named it sweat it's the first
time any a non-english movie has won
best film and I also I feel like no
Awards no movies really sweep the award
shows anymore cuz like everyone's a
winner no nuts in some dog millionaire
no but like last year literally each
movie won one of each category sweetie
wives for a sweetie vibe to happen in
2020 it must be fabulous it was a big
deal and so he that the director has won
four Oscars last night which is a tie
for the most ever won in a night
Katherine Hepburn also one time one for
and one night so he now holds a record
with Katharine Hepburn and I just think
it's it's fabulous and I think Walt
Disney has won five and if he had won
one more he would have tied with Walt
Disney I saw a headline oh really cuz I
saw that the most ever won in the night
I googled it Katharine Hepburn that was
like that he missed it by one oh really
yeah
Leo and Camilla Marone become awards
show official we know it's a big deal
for him to take a usually takes his mom
to road shows they didn't walk the
carpet but they sat right in front she
looked stellar I mean she's just
perfectly good was the snatchler like I
guess I understand like why it's her and
not me but it's still pretty sad I
buried it yet you know it's hard to see
someone you love I'm happy for them
me too they're really cute I'm probably
for her like get across yeah laura dern
won her first ever Oscar fabulous okay
marriage story like was nominated for a
lot I didn't think it was better than
only any of the other movies but I did
happen to think Lauren's performance was
[ __ ] amazing and it made the movie
like a little bit more tolerable and I'm
so happy for I just like can't believe
like she was the obvious frontrunner she
won the Golden Globe I think a lot of
people thought she was gonna win and she
showed up in that dress with like titty
tassels on it was just it was nothing of
the sort and I'm glad that she won
because otherwise the night like would
have been a big loss for her yeah I
liked her dress terrible Eminem
surprised everyone with lose yourself no
he confused everyone yeah does anyone
know like what so he cheated that they
won they won an Oscar for lose herself
when it came out at eight-mile years ago
yeah and 18 years ago yeah Eminem didn't
show up to accept the award and I think
in a lot of ways
last night was him showing up I don't
know because he posted on his Twitter
the clip of them winning but him not
being there and being like 18 years man
like a dude it so I think that's it
it's just weird because most of the
performances were just the song of the
year yeah so it's just weird when it's
not yeah also Renee Zellweger won Best
Actress yes she had a very boring speech
but she looked snatch that one-armed
raciss was everything her and Bradley
Cooper used to date she liked by the way
she went through like a weird period in
her life where she like married Kenny
Chesney on the beach for five minutes
and I'll never forget those pictures
they were actually so cute like you
thought they would have lasted a
lifetime but they were married for like
two weeks sooner that doesn't surprise
me
and they reunited well by reunited they
saw each other and yeah I don't work
event yeah no I don't think that it was
like the greatest I don't think it was
the reunion we've been waiting for no
but I like her I'm happy me too I didn't
see Judi um but now and I think Judi I
saw the beginning of Judi cuz doc was
watching and I just kept coming in back
watching
sure I can't
I think it took him that's so funny took
him five hours I don't even know if he'd
finished the movie oh my god I would not
stop hysterical his stare and I would
come in like Oh what had like because I
wasn't watching and I would be like
what's this about she died but she
didn't die out of it eventually everyone
just looked so fantastic and it really
made me realize like I realized that I'm
super far you know from the Oscars like
I don't think I'll ever actually meet
invited um but if I am it's just like I
gotta get my outfit ready like I think I
need to head over to the reel reel and
get my Oscar dress ready I think you
need like a couture gown from the reel
reel but do you think I need a suture of
course you can own iconic luxury items
at an unreal value with the real wheel
the leading reseller of authenticated
luxury consignment from top designers
like Louis Vuitton Gucci rolex cartier
and hundreds more at up to ninety
percent off retail shopping the sign
women's and men's luxury fashion and
street wear as well as fine jewelry
watches art and home new arrivals come
in daily and every item undergoes a real
rales meticulous authentication process
in fact the real real employees over a
hundred Brent specialist gemologist
serologist and art curators from around
the globe who inspect thousands of items
each day to ensure that every item is
authenticated you can shop luxury but
the sustainable way go online download
the app or visit one of their stores in
West Hollywood's Soho or their newest
location at 870 Madison Avenue in New
York and if you want to consign which
Jackie and I both our customers and
consigners at the rail reel you can try
out their White Glove service for free
in-home pick up today shop in store
online or download the app and get 20%
off select items with the promo code
real that's the real real calm promo
code real for 20% off select items the
bag that I'm wearing shades from the
real real it's just it's everything of
the sort and I think Tiffany Pollard
would agree everything of the sort okay
next up Kylie Jenner and Khloe
Kardashian celebrate pregnant Malika
Hawk at beauty shop baby shower which
was the most beautiful baby shower I've
ever seen stunning it was cool everyone
had to wear a shade of cream or gray
which is like a very specific borderline
annoying dress code but it it looked
amazing all those you know I was gonna
say pimples but they're balloons but
they looks like pimples all those
balloons
it was star-studded that Kardashians
were there the bjurman 's were there
Dorothy Wang was there like it looks
like so much fun
it was very bear themed Oh cute I love
to the Bears yeah I wonder like who paid
for that I think Chloe I think Chloe in
combination with like sponsorships from
like Mindy Wyson and Jeff Letha because
like she tagged them all and the Beverly
Hills Hotel yeah her Instagram but I
think at this point like these parties
pay for themselves because the velvet
brackets so much press yeah so I don't
think Mindy Weiss is like out here
planning parties for free uh not for
free but like I think the business that
she gets from being the Kardashian yes
pays for itself when they were having
the argument over the Candyland kids
seem tolerated party was it many ways
are they raising someone else sorry
maybe yeah there was in for like there
cuz Sharon's like they're friends with
Chris got it they have a lot of
different planners that they use well
cuz they have a lot of different parties
they do it all so we totally forgot to
mention but today is it such an exciting
day because we have some merch dropping
today some hot and toasty March um the
booty it's as hot and toasty on the
booty this is a size medium super cute
it's a hot and toasty bundles so you got
a pair of underwear and three toasty
condoms yep that's right we made custom
condoms so these go live at noon today
so if you want the undies or the condoms
they're sold together three condoms the
undies so cute they're black they're
stretchy a nice soft elastic waistband
because you know I hate when my weight
spends like digging into my Fupa so
painful they're so cute right just in
time for Valentine's Day just in time
for Valentine's Day so make sure to head
over we still have a few flasks up on
the site for the tipsy toasters out
there these are pearls gold flasks these
are our subgroup artists so if you're
like living for the subgroups um we got
hot toasty bi tipsy toasters and we got
a few more coming so get drunk this
Valentine's Day here either if you're
single on Valentine's Day get the flask
if you're not get the undies in the
condoms okay yes I think that's a fair
assessment love it
shot morning toast comm she didn't want
to forget we have a lot to cover today
yes we do anyway so the guests I'm so
happy for Malika I love the baby shower
I loved the content it was so premium
like it was the theme I love asking him
um I love a theme and you know what's
frustrating about throwing a party with
a theme is like the potential of someone
not cooperating you know like if my
theme is incumbent upon people like
wearing costumes and then that person
doesn't show up in costume it's so
frustrating yeah maybe you have like a
couple dresses in the back way
or someone could change into or you keep
them to the curb because it's so
disrespectful right like so two years
ago I had a um country western themed
birthday party and for the most part
people showed up like a couple of Ben's
friends did and it was like so annoying
and rude but I have the cowboy hats in
like little bandanas everywhere like
people could throw on but it's just
honestly it's like if you're not gonna
come to my party and participate like
please don't come well I feel like what
the costume it's different cuz everyone
could just like pretend that there's
something but when you've a strict color
palette and someone says comes wearing
red when it's a out of control then you
have to go home I'm sorry agreed this is
my party get the [ __ ] out you're ruining
the photos okay
next story really weird this new
bachelor commercial that aired during
the Oscars The Bachelor channels ghost
get a behind-the-scenes look at Peter
Webb Z's Webber sexy Oscars perm oh okay
this was the commercial that nobody
asked for yet everyone had to endure
where Peter Webber is I surrounded by a
bunch of different ladies hands while
recreating a scene from ghost I didn't
even realize it was an odd tone you know
that you know that famous scene where
they know I don't and women are doing
the ceramics no I didn't realize it was
like a movie thing I just felt like
weird and uncomfortable the whole time
yeah it was a movie thing but then they
made it into like um you know their
polygamy sort of things right and it was
just I feel like they're really
overcompensating like I don't remember
any other bachelor/bachelorette who got
like a commercial during the Oscars I
think people are really turning on Peter
yeah and this is like an attempt to
either make it worse or make it better
but it definitely made it worse
but Whoopi Goldberg made it better
Whoopi she was in the commercial she was
yes she comes off at the she comes in at
the end she said Peter you in danger boy
oh I actually love what we go over she
actually can salvage pretty much
anything but I do think that this was
beyond salvation
um I but I do I am really confused as to
what's gonna happen this season because
it's not gonna be what we're used to I
know that just because I can't see it
know and it hasn't been spoiled yet
which means that the ending is different
it's not a traditional ending I don't
think a girl wins the other doesn't pick
anyone there's a theory that it's his
producer but the evidence I saw was so
thin that I think literally ABC put that
out for us to make us think that but I'm
not that dumb no the evident there is no
evidence it's like Semillon was like
okay let's start a theory that Peters in
love with his producer and then they
went and found like comments
like to shoehorn into the theory and
that's just not how theories work and
it's just not even close to being true
no I mean like watch how it is true but
something's weird with the end of the
season something happens between or
could be Hanna yeah the fact that we
always Steve hasn't figured out who won
means that something is happening right
yeah I don't know I'm just gonna try and
like enjoy it you know yeah it's on
tonight like oh my god it's just me just
and literally because it was on twice
last week I feel who watched it
yesterday I'm just not ready no but I
guess it's always better when there's
less people six girls now it's like an
attainable number I hate feeling
overwhelmed by people whose names I
don't remember they're all named Tana
like I find it I do find certain parts
of the bachelor in the beginning of the
season to be very overwhelming and it
makes it unenjoyable so now with six
girls like I know all their names I know
where they're from like I know their
deal I feel like I'm more equipped to
get to get started here's an interesting
theory someone said that goes to the
movie that it's referencing is meaning
someone from his past is coming a ka
Hana okay they didn't final story a
little um travel news which I just found
interesting and also there wasn't much
else that happened this week another
billion dancers and the fact that like
I'm a part of the blog squad Oh for
sharing the fact that the redheads book
club first episode came out and
everyone's just thoroughly enjoying it
everyone's talking about how reading
just getting back into reading has just
been so beneficial for them and the fact
that our merch launches today shot
morning shows calm 12 p.m. Eastern Time
and the fact that we sell some flasks up
on the site for you shot morning toast
comments just saw very exciting and
other items like the Jerry Jean story
times a lot of the stuff sold out the
beanies are gone but check it out we
also have a lot of stuff on sale yes oh
stuff yeah if you just like want to get
some toasting merch my whole closet is
toasty merch like I don't know how I
ever lived without toast oh and that's
another thing about david dobrik
it makes me really good feel good to
realize we are not the only people who
exclusively wear their own March no I
mean the Kardashians only wear their own
stuff too like they only wear Kanye's
clothes oh that's true I guess like
their own make up in their own skin yes
and their own everything now I got the
skin food tape she did and I FaceTime
Jackie I definitely put it on
incorrectly but I just jumped think the
product is for me like I do think I'm
beyond the weight limit breast wise
so I look I wanted to take a picture and
like but I'm just not that brave like
I'm not even close to being that I do
think maybe I would retry it like with
someone else doing it for me like seeing
Kim put it on the other girl's boobs
like it's hard to like tape your own
tits up
so tape your back yeah you know what you
should do you should just wrap it under
your armpit a few times like for sure
but that every time you lift your arms
like your tits would go up beauty is
pain
it was interesting I'm gonna try it
again but I don't think that it's a
product for me a British Airways flight
has set a record crossing the Atlantic
in under five hours and strong winds
this is wow really really amazing
where was the flight going to um it went
from New York City to London it's
supposed to be more than six hours but
it was under five which just feels like
an exciting development I have a theory
that like the government it's like
stopping us from getting to places like
I do think that it shouldn't take six
hours to get from New York to LA like
we're in the same [ __ ] country it
makes no goddamn sense and I just have a
feeling that like the government's
trying to stop us from getting where we
need to go so the fact that this plane
got to across the pond in under five
hours is just reinforcing that theory
yeah it was just it was propelled by
strong winds and it wasn't like they
were trying to break any records or
anything but they broke the they broke
the record it's weird how wind can also
impact your flight time like it can make
it longer on shorter yeah like when you
fly back from LA
it's an hour shorter because the wind
it's crazy it's so strange it's so
strange remember the Concorde like I
don't I wasn't on no but like that used
to be a thing yeah like at the end of
Parent Trap yeah they get their first
like you do the Cohn code right yeah and
it's like where's the Concorde
yeah please someone help we're anybody
enemy so this was interesting it took
hours in 56 minutes wow that is so short
see you can get to London in four hours
and 56 minutes but it still takes you
six hours to get to [ __ ] LA from New
York even though we're on the same
[ __ ] country yeah there's
something they're not telling us there's
something they're not telling us okay
well we have a very exciting guest today
Madeline Arthur who placed Chris onto
all the Y's Ella before is joining us
momentarily I'm very excited I have a
lot of questions for the sequel drops
this week which I feel like happens so
fast all the pictures from the premiere
coming out and they're so [ __ ] cute
like everyone's looking so snatched and
it's such an exciting time for this
dropping I know
young Hollywood yes that's what
just fabulous and the Netflix red carpet
was like premium looks like a wedding
with like flowers everywhere I love I
love a Netflix budget me too
so we're gonna bring her out if you have
any questions for her drop it in the
YouTube stream our guest segment is
brought to you by Squarespace
all in one domains websites online
stores and marketing tools from websites
and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business plus they
have a brand new feature our email
campaigns where you could say more and
sell more you could stand out in any
inbox with squarespace's
email campaigns they're all in one
platform makes it easy to unify your
brand voice from your homepage to your
emails it's important to have consistent
content from your website to your emails
and they have powerful editing tools to
make it your own you can create a
beautiful website with Squarespace as
well turn your cool idea into a website
showcase your work a blog or published
content sell products or services
announce an upcoming event or special
project you get to own your domain and
promote your business and they does this
by giving you beautiful templates to
create world created by world-class
designers and powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online you have the ability to
customize look and feel settings
products and more with just a few clicks
everything is optimized for mobile write
outside the box nothing it's free and
secure hosting and people using
Squarespace can choose how to use it
whether you want to like I said blog
don't you want to follow your passion of
blogging Jackie yeah if you're gonna
have a secret project or a special
project like that's so exciting
then you need a website and you got to
check out Squarespace you've gotta and
if you check out squarespace.com sush
toast for a free trial when you're ready
to launch your website use the offer
code toast to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain so go
to squarespace.com slash toast use the
offer code toast when you're ready to
launch your website and you'll save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain Thank You Squarespace for
sponsoring this segment we are going to
take a quick break and bring out our
guests we are so excited again if you
have a question for her drop it in the
YouTube stream we love you we'll see you
in a minute
see you in a minute make sure to check
out the redheads book club leave us a
review 5 stars please mwah
of course we are back with our guest
Medellin Arthur from to all the boys
I've loved before ooh very excited to
have you here because what we've
recapped that movie on this show we both
were like damn we love Chris everyone
needs a friend like Chris so thank you
for being here yes entertaining me doing
press I'm sure you're very busy this is
a big sequel it is it's so exciting I
can't believe that we're already here
doing the sequel we wrapped the third
movie back at the beginning of September
and to have the second one coming out
already it's just amazing the
turnarounds so fast like for the fans
this is everything totally I mean having
shot the first movie a couple years ago
now and then we got to step back into
those characters and be with the whole
cast again and we really became like a
family over the course of filming three
it was kind of like filming a season of
a TV series right yeah so much fun it's
also really crazy how that movie changed
everyone's lives it was just supposed to
be like a cute little movie and it was
it was everything and we loved it I
think people really connected with it
and now it's like large gene and Peter
Kaminski like they're all perfect and
then like John Ambrose comes to ruin it
and you're largely you're such a good
friend to Lara Jean you know and I
really feel like everyone needs like a
Chris in their life and so can you talk
to me about your audition process did
you know of the books before did you
read them I was aware of the books and
then as soon as I got further into the
audition process and landed the role I
read all of them and loved all of them
and it was pretty standard auditioning
process when for Chris in and then all
of a sudden I had the good fortune to do
the first movie and as you said like we
had no idea we couldn't have imagined
that right I have this huge impact so to
have gotten to track her journey over so
many movies and see her and lodgings
friendship evolved was was such a dream
when you were filming it did you guys
like know that you had something special
or did it just feel like a regular
project well I knew we had something
special in the sense that there were
really good people involved and we were
led by the beautiful Juana playing Laura
Jean but with anything you kind of you
put it all you do your best work and you
just hope that the project finds an
audience
people do appreciate it and enjoy it and
so you can never I think if you go in
expecting that you can often be very
disappointed when it doesn't really soar
like to all the boys did so yeah yeah
and was also the like the first in a
string of movies that came out on
Netflix that just like we're served to
these really big audience that results
yeah you guys like set the precedent for
like this is the new Twilight you know
but it's it but it's not being put out
in theaters the way it used to be but
this is the new way of watching your
favorite movies exactly I mean Netflix
gave rom-coms kind of helped with the
resurgence of that whole we miss them so
much
so to have them help bring back this
yarn to be a part of that and now we see
they they made tall girl and and all
those and all sorts of other romantic
comedies yeah it's really cute and we're
gonna take some questions from Instagram
that we got got a lot of questions
people are really excited about this
this is from kkj bebe have you seen your
co-star Jourdan Fisher who's playing
John Ambrose have you seen him in dear
Ivan Hanson yet I'm seeing him tomorrow
night and I am so excited for he's great
I am sure I have no doubt that he is
extraordinary he's a triple threat
totally oh my god that's gonna be
amazing that show is so good so many
what are you gonna cry oh yeah really
interfering ready I mean I am because
I've been waiting yeah but at the same
time am i emotionally prepared I have no
idea and then she developed question
which is how was he having him as an
addition to the cast oh he brought such
a terrific energy to the set he's such a
gentleman and he's very fun-loving and I
wish we had had more scenes together
yeah oh good well so for those who don't
know he plays John Ambrose who was one
of the recipients of the first five
letters but he wasn't in the movie cuz
he like move or something whatever he
just didn't get it at the end of the
last movie had the credits which you
turn the odd half to the credits which
most people do you didn't see that John
Ambrose got the letter so it left like a
little bit of a cliffhanger
I didn't realize that that's who this
cat was so he gives the letter and you
basically just play like a super
supportive friend you're there for large
who do you ship large in with in real
life and as your character Peter Jordan
Fischer John Ambrose Oh Chris
ships large in with whoever Lara Jean is
most happy with and supported by and
allows her to be her most authentic self
with myself kind of the same thing I
think they both have such positive
attributes III I personally cannot
choose right that's why I feel like this
movie is gonna be confusing for me
because I was watching the trailer and
being like no one can break up large
even Peter I don't like Jordan Fisher is
like so cute he's not like a villain
he's just a nice guy yeah so you do like
both of them it's like Edward and Jacob
know Jacob was problematic no you're
right like I could see how someone can
use Team Edward or Jacob it's crazy to
hear these comparisons to like Twilight
saying that because that was such a
movie of absolutely Jacob I I don't know
I was again I was split I did love team
Jacob but man Robert Pattinson amazing
thing you started talking I was handsome
man in the world according to a science
according to science Wow in a movie
based on a book like a having read the
books make it easier for you to
understand like the world of the
character and like their innermost
thoughts like does it help guide how
you're gonna show the character on
screen
absolutely and thanks to Jenny Han for
creating these this dynamic group of
characters and whenever you have source
material to go back to and and help
influence your decisions and see where
they're coming from because movies are a
different medium than books you can't
get everything that's on the page into
the movie so to just have that help with
with your backstory of course yeah is so
lovely did you originally audition for
the role of Kris or do you audition for
any of the other parts in the movie I
actually I I just infer for two roles
when I first went in because they they
gave me the option to audition for two
roles and that I always think so
why didn't I yes yes to audition for
both what was I do I addition for both
Chris and Jen so right yes yes Jen is
Jen in the sequel she is and she's has
some really lovely scenes Amelia at bran
says she's she become nicer I can't say
much but she's pretty
but I love her at Chris and Chris and
Jen still have a little animosity which
means I'm able to I love her personally
we're really good for yeah it's hard to
like you guys where do you guys shoot
the movies so the second one we shot in
Vancouver the first and second in
Vancouver and then the third one we
actually we shot here in New York for a
little bit oh and then Vancouver and
then they shot in Seoul a little bit Wow
did you like shooting in Vancouver
people love it I heard it's like so cool
and trendy yes I it's a it's a good City
there's a lot of good food there's a
beautiful landscape scenery with the
mountains yeah yeah in the ocean and
filming here in New York was awesome
amazing English it would be so hopeful
it's hectic but I feel like I thrive in
chaos yeah yeah I loved it we were in so
many iconic locations I said I didn't
see this movie I can't wait and I'd hate
to jump ahead but like when is the third
one gonna come out I have no idea I'm
equally as excited as I announced with
the premise of a third one I read the
books well you have to see the second
one and I don't know this exactly I
don't wanna spoil anything about the
third okay but it's I'm kind of biased
but I'm very excited about the third
there yeah there's some good there's
some good there's some good scene you
know this is just such like a good clean
fun happy movie like no one can't like
it you know yeah I love right uplifting
thank you when does that become out of
comes out this week right it does it
comes out the 12 so good night oh that's
so exciting well thank you so much for
being here thank you next let's thank
you to awesomenesstv for making these
incredible movies yeah we have just come
to maybe more get more content thank you
for being here everyone follow metal
into Instagram and that allows for
premium content thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so every watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up and leave a
comment we're also available as podcasts
and we're podcasts we found sets about
if I action sit your public video I hear
we do cashbox so ever you choose listen
to podcasts find us the morning toast hi
how are you leave a review maybe five
stars comment about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys so much we'll see you tomorrow bye
that was very